[Music]
foreign
brought to you by the every dollar app
start budgeting for free today Mary is
starting us off in St Louis hi Mary
welcome to the Ramsey Show hi Dave
thanks for taking my call sure what's up
so the last few weeks to be honest I've
gone down a little bit of a Dave Ramsey
rabbit hole on YouTube so I'm just kind
of getting to know your principles I'm
really intrigued by them uh but I have a
real question about your baby steps the
one thousand dollar emergency fund
philosophy I think my husband and I
might be a little out of whack when it
comes to following the steps
um exactly correct we have a sixteen
thousand dollar car loan we have a 215
000 mortgage and we have about 30 000 in
non-retirement Investments
um and we've also started a few small
investment accounts for our children
we're trying to increase our retirement
to 15. we're kind of trying to do
everything at one time yeah
um my question they did all of that long
before you even heard of us
yeah
we've been trying to save you know as
much as possible it's good for you to
really you know try to pay off his car
loans and things like that so we have
one car run left
um my question is this it's taken us
several years to save that money that we
have and then non-retirement investment
and we currently have a deck in our
backyard that is literally falling apart
so we've been quoted to remove it and
replace it with a patio for about
fifteen thousand dollars
um what's your household income
uh about 145. okay cool
um so I guess my question is and I you
know I also am worried if we use the
money to pay off the car loan and then
we do the patio I just always like
having some cushion to know that if
there are big purchases that come up
um that we have enough cash to do it and
so I guess I just wanted to know what
your philosophy was on based on
everything you know where we're at
um the summary of the background of the
baby steps was this when I first started
teaching uh basic financial principles
30 years ago I would have this exact
conversation with people where do I
start
where do I start where do I start and uh
a couple of philosophies emerged
um as we worked with thousands and
thousands of people now millions of
people years later but uh the
philosophies number one that emerged was
the number one wealth building tool that
you have is your income when you give it
to other people in the form of payments
you limit or slow down or even stop your
ability to build wealth
so becoming debt free first personal
later home is an essential part of a
long-term wealth building plan
because the money you make 145 000
should turn you into a millionaire
okay if you don't give it all to someone
else in the form of car payments etc etc
right and that's the general philosophy
okay the general philosophy number two
was people kept saying where do I start
because 100 of us including no matter
how much money you make
uh have competing priorities we have a
broken down deck we have a uh a uh an
emotional need for a pad of an emergency
fund laying there
um we have high school kids they're
gonna be going to college soon college
kids coming at us we've got life
insurance we need we've got a next car
we might need to purchase we've got
another thing we've got to think about
Christmas God it's going to be here
again in 20 minutes you know and we've
got all these things coming at us and so
the what we came up with was the baby
steps and the reason they've been so
successful is uh because it gives you a
very clear path
uh that is based in good solid financial
planning principles and a get out of
debt philosophy and it's the shortest
distance between where you are and
wealth now that it might not be the
shortest distance between where you are
in a deck
but it's the shortest distance between
where you are and wealth and that's what
the whole thing's built on and so what
we would tell you to do is have a
thousand dollars first any other
non-retirement money you have the thirty
thousand bucks in your case would be to
come become debt free except your home
so we pay off your car by the time you
by the time dinner is here tonight you
pay off the car okay then that leaves
you um fourteen thousand dollars and you
have a debt problem and you make 145 000
so we need to get a deck fixed you have
any money in savings at all other than
this non-retirement
um we have about
um we have a small state All State
account is about five thousand right so
that would keep some of that other
though but instead of the deck for your
emergency fund because when you said I
just want to have some cushion that's
what that provides you and then you guys
make great money and I would just cash
flow put in yeah put in the budget hey
we're gonna save x amount per month
towards the deck and let's pretend okay
so you make 100 you're right Richard you
make 145 let's call 20 000 your
emergency fund which would probably be
about right and you never touch that
ever for anything it's not for purchases
yep a bass boat another car is not an
emergency
okay okay this is only if the world come
to an end I mean only if the
transmission goes out only if your
mother or your relative or whoever in
another state passed away and you got to
buy an airline ticket I mean only as an
emergency an unexpected event a deck
falling off is gradual that's not
unexpected yeah okay so to Rachel's
point we're gonna put 20 000 bucks there
now you got no car payment and now
you're going to get on a detailed budget
and start working these plans uh and I
would save up for that deck very rapidly
I think you can save for that deck by
Christmas
okay
and and then you pay cash for it oh by
the way in the winter the guys aren't
working as much
in St Louis
and so you might get a better deal
yeah okay then a deck in the summer I
could be wrong but I think so
and so and so on okay now we got a deck
and now we got baby step five four is 15
of your income going to retirement you
already got the kids college going you
already got that going and now let's
start just thinking about how are we
going to knock out this little 215 000
mortgage it's not much you sound young
how young are you I'm 34. yeah
so I mean you guys same age right so
yeah
um 35 35 but basically it's just close
enough yeah but I mean that's the when
you're my age it's really cool
yeah so anyway the point is the uh uh uh
you know you're gonna
gosh you should have this house paid off
before you're 40. yeah y'all are going
to see a lot of traction Mary because
you guys you already have the Instinct
you've been doing this and like you said
it's everything's a little bit all over
you just need more of a concise plan but
there's no power and you're going to see
it in lack of focus focusing and working
straight down those baby steps gives you
a power uh because it keeps you from
doing other stuff when you try to do six
things at once nothing gets done
but you can do one thing you can get the
one thing done and so we got the car and
we got the deck now we got the
retirement we got the kids college going
now we're gonna start working on the
house one thing